as of May 2008 Dean twitch had 118
million active monthly users who watched
a total of over 720 million hours of
watch time in a single month we just
created thousands of gaming communities
covering pretty much every game on every
device and his united people all over
the world however there is also strong
competition from corporate giants like
Microsoft and Google as he also offers
streaming services but despite this
seems to be the preferred choice among
millions of people so why is Twitter so
popular make sure to stick around till
the end to find out
[Music]
welcome to Horry sorry so it all started
with a website called justin.tv in 2007
which is created by four friends whose
names were Justin you can amateur
Michael Seibel and Kyle walked this was
founded as an Internet start-up in San
Francisco and was funded by Paul Graham
from Y Combinator the original justin.tv
was just a single channel featuring
Justin thus the name on March 19 2007
for some reason he decided to record
every single portion of his life in
streaming online he wore a baseball cap
with a webcam on it and was Fremont lion
with a laptop in his backpack and this
is how Justin that TV was started and by
the summer of 2007 there were over 60
channels on their web site by August of
2007 there's two new channels being
added every single day
most of these were people streaming
their lives or event streamers on
October 2nd 2007 Justin thought TV
became a public network and anyone could
stream on there and in just a couple of
months by April of 2008 they had over
30,000 broadcaster accounts because of
this large number of people who are
trying to stream content is split all up
into different categories things like
people in life casting music and radio
and of course gaming there are several
other categories as well but the gaming
category was the one that grew the
fastest and became most popular the
traffic was so high take gaming category
and June of 2011 they decided to make
the gaming category a dedicated website
and it was called twitch.tv the name
twitch is based on twitch gaming or fast
response gaming
by 2014 twitch.tv was generating so much
more revenue than all other categories
that they decided to rename the main
company twitch interactive and that same
year just a couple of months later they
resorted to Amazon for 970 million
dollars and that's how they switch that
we know today was created so why is
Twitter so popular
first of all streamers have a lot more
potential on twitch not on YouTube
gaming or Microsoft Beam to achieve
partner status on twitch.tv there are no
number requirements and it is on a case
by case basis but once you do become a
partner you can get subscribers who pay
between five to $25 twitch does take a
cut from that but it's still pretty good
especially compared to YouTube gaming we
have to have at least one thousand
subscribers and at least four thousand
hours of watch time in the past twelve
months and after all that work you only
can get money from ad revenue you don't
get money from subscribers because it's
free as for ad revenue it's pretty much
identical on Twitch and on YouTube
gaming most of the money that you will
make on either platform what come from
sponsorships or brand deals they also
both have donations which YouTube caused
super chat but YouTube takes a 30% cut
of all donations while twitch takes a 0%
cut you also have to deal with Apple
service fees so you essentially had to
pay Apple and Google now granted that is
only for iOS and Mac users but that's a
pretty significant proportion on top of
this merchandise sales are a lot better
on twitch as twitch is partnered with an
apparel company you can sell your
general brand by posting pictures of
branded t-shirts and hoodies on a on
dashboard on Twitch
and when someone orders that country
takes care of everything from
manufacturing to shipping this not only
maximizes the profits as it's all
through one company but makes a whole
process so much more convenient you can
simply make a lot more money with twitch
as there are no hefty fees for donations
you can potentially make money earlier
we have subscription revenue and making
merchandise is a lot easier it just
makes more sense for streamers as they
put in the same amount of work but
receive more compensation people often
complain about twitch students
especially compared to YouTube gaming
now this is true YouTube is a lot more
lenient
or spammers and will offenders you get
three strands before you're out with
twitch you can easily get banned for
simple offences but twitch is actually a
lot more lenient for streamers compared
to YouTube gaming this is especially
true for monetization for example if you
have copyrighted music on your streams
Twitter will simply edit it out and you
will have no negative effects attached
to this incident but with YouTube gaming
YouTube immediately first monetization
and takes all of our points of pay the
content claimer your content will
basically be observed in the music
industry
as your earning revenue for the music
industry they even force ads on to
archived stream footage if they
infringes on copyright which is really
frustrating for many YouTube dreamers
and the thing is twitch is a lot more
lenient with streamers as streamers are
their main source of revenue YouTube
gaming is just one small part of YouTube
which is just a small part of Google no
matter how big of a YouTube gimme
streamer you are you won't even account
for a rounding error for google
even if YouTube completely fails Google
will do just fine but that's not the
case with twitch they need your
streamers and this is why twitch is a
lot more lenient forgiving than YouTube
gaming for streamers and that makes the
preferred choice in several occasions
the website UI is arguably better than
YouTube gaming as a arkla straight for
uncluttered experience let's be honest
here YouTube gaming is just a youtube
website with a chat on the side now this
is not necessarily a bad thing as a
YouTube interface is already pretty good
it's just that it is not creative for
streaming twitch.tv is also pretty
similar as the player in the middle and
the chat on the right but two small
things that make the difference for
example if you're watching this dream
and it's about to end or getting bored
you want to look for a new stream on
YouTube gaming you'd have to close out
of the original one for some reason
YouTube hasn't made it possible to
minimize the stream that you're
currently watching to the right side and
then look for a new stream twitch this
on all of their platforms and YouTube
even offers this on a mobile app for
some reason though they're lacking on a
desktop mode twitch also has an
advantage as it recently released a
dedicate
desktop app while YouTube gaming does
not have one and the thing is people
have used twitch for so long and they're
so used to it that they don't want to
change and twitch as platforms are not
the best on every single device YouTube
gave me a pass got a lot of praise for
being a lot better than twitch but with
twitch it's not just a UI that people
really like it's the actual function
that it provides as I said before it's
so much easier discovering new channels
on Twitch this is because streams
broadcasting live are beautifully
organized by game console and channel
and of course you can use a search bar
if you're looking for something really
specific twitch communities are also a
lot larger much more diverse than a
YouTube gaming community this makes it
so there's actually more things to
discover you can find a great new chinos
every single day it might even develop a
new game interest by having the overall
better UI and a much larger community
the user experience is a lot better on
Twitch and last point it didn't create a
much stronger community as all of your
subscribers are much more loyal to
become a twitch subscriber you have to
pay money but to become a Youtube
subscriber is free as it is evident
Chris chips garbage are a lot more
useful to streamers than YouTube
subscribers this also leads to a much
more reliable revenue stream coming from
twitch if you don't have brand deals on
YouTube you're pretty much reliant on
number of user were getting as that's
how ad revenue is calculated on twitch
even if you have a bad month and get a
low number of views and air streams you
can count on your subscribers of course
you're supporting ad revenue would
decrease but this is a lot better than
losing most of your revenue like you
would with YouTube gaming and your
twitch community is also a lot more
likely to support you in ways other than
money they clearly liked your content
enough to pay for it and as a result
they're a lot more understanding those
take with you and support you even if
you take a week off for vacation or
emergency occurs but with YouTube gaming
subscribers you're not nearly as invest
in your content if you don't stream for
some time they'll quickly forget about
you and even unsubscribe and even if
they don't you'll probably just get lost
in their subscription feed so clearly
you can build a lot stronger community
on Twitch so clearly purchase a lot of
things off
their competitors don't have but twitch
lead does need to be careful as her
competitors are rising quickly and
already YouTube gaming offers a better
mobile experience and twitch and this
has led to many mobile streamers to
prefer YouTube gaming it is also a lot
easier for monetize YouTube channels
move over to YouTube gaming now your
YouTube subscribers don't translate onto
YouTube gaming account however it is a
lot easier to convert free subscribers
rather than converting free subscribers
to paid subscribers on Twitch and
eventually the differences between the
streaming services will disappear and
they'll all be equally good and
considering the developing power that
Microsoft and Google have this will
occur pretty quickly so from the
consumer side it's pretty much all the
same they might even prefer Microsoft
and YouTube services so for twins to
continue their successful domination
they need to keep their streamers and
that's how they can stick out they need
to make sure that they have a loyal base
of streamers which is advantages that
I've carried on to this position won't
carry them to the next step this is what
will actually drive traffic to twitch
rather than YouTube gaming or being the
consumer experience will pretty much
become identical between all of them if
not better for YouTube gaming and Beam
so for twitch to stick out they need to
have a unique base of streamers and to
do this they need to continue to be very
supportive of streamers or else it's
honestly just a matter of time before
YouTube or Microsoft takeover I really
do believe a twitch and continue to be
successful but to do so I believe that
they need to provide unique content that
can't be found anywhere else twitch was
the pioneer in live streaming games and
has proved to be vastly successful for
them and of course big corporate giants
have followed along with their own
offerings so far though preach seems to
be the dominant player market as they
offer streamers much more potential and
seem to be a fan favorite but to keep
this lead I believe that twitch has to
offer something YouTube and Microsoft
can't offer as such huge corporation
which is better support for streamers
and users and if they do that I'm sure
that people will always be on the side
but that's all I have for you guys on
twitch where should come
down below what company you would like
me to cover next also if you guys liked
this video they measure drop a like and
consider subscribe if you like to see
more videos just like this one but till
then I'm Hari I'll see you guys on next
one